can you tell by my voice I have a cold
it's the worst my wife hates me for
having a cold I hate the world for
having a cold [ __ ] all colds we continue
in the practice of you know me doing
this well wife and baby are at home
everything is well with them but we
still got some bank shows to do this
week is New Year's so if you're around
Orange County in that area
I'm at Brea in Prague in Brea California
all weekend long two shows on the 31st
one on the first two on the second and
one on the third all weekend at the Brea
Improv in Brea California a couple of
weeks from now
oh [ __ ] or whatever January 13 14 15 16
downtown Denver Comedy Works pretty
stoked to be doing that that is
absolutely one of the best clubs in the
country one of my favorite places to go
and then flappers everyone always asked
me about doing shows in Los Angeles I'm
doing four shows in Burbank flappers
comedy club January 22nd and 23rd and
Salt Lake titties wiseguys February 5th
and 6th those tickets are all on sale so
make sure you scoop them up now I think
that's that what else is there to say oh
yeah this is the first time I've been
able to announce it really they gave me
permission finally some of you know from
Twitter and Facebook etc but for the
rest of you
chips and a ball man I could finally
tell you my new one-hour special mostly
stories will start streaming on Netflix
January 8th you heard it here so January
8th it's available worldwide I know some
people have hit me up and asked why they
can't see completely normal in certain
countries on Netflix because of the
licensing deal it was only available to
a few countries but this new one mostly
stories will be available in every
country that has Netflix it's a
worldwide release so I hope you enjoy it
I hope you check it out and give it five
stars man you know how it is I am really
thrilled about it so I couldn't be
happier that it's coming out in just a
couple of weeks what else is there to
tell you this episode is brought to you
by harrys.com why pay thirty two dollars
for an eight pack of blades when it's
half the price at Harry's satisfaction
is guaranteed
Harry's manufacturers our own blades
high-quality high-performing German
blades crafted by shaving experts I
don't even know that was a thing another
shaving experts but there are at
harrys.com they are about half the price
of the other big branded blades and most
of you are probably sick of paying those
big branded prices man they robbed you
you will buy the refilled it's
ridiculous
Harry's razors offers a high quality
shade that's better for your face and
your wallet their starter set is an
amazing deal for 15 bucks you get a
razor foaming shave gel or shave cream
three razor blades plus free shipping we
gave it's a top dog we got him a hairy
set for the holidays and he absolutely
loved it we had some family drama and
here's what he's texted me this morning
not even addressing our family
it just says by the way I love the new
razor
that's from top dog so he's a big fan
love of Harry's go to harrys.com now and
Harry's will give you five dollars off
the starter set and use our coupon code
mom with your first purchase that's H a
are our YS dot-com enter coupon code M
om the word mom at checkout and you get
five dollars off harrys.com start
shaving better today you can you hear
how bad my god this feels so gross hate
being sick really
what is worse I'd rather [ __ ] I would
rather fight in a civil war for from I
don't know four years then then be sick
for a minute I had to take a breather
there I did it actually stop just to
breathe all right real quick I also had
to tell you about our favorite mattress
in the whole wide world that is from
satva sa a TVA it's the mattress that
your mother and I Christina sleep on
we bought one because we were tired of
basically poor sleep and we wanted to up
our game but we didn't want to spend ten
thousand dollars doing it so we ordered
from sattva it's the leading online
luxury mattress brand that designs
manufactures and installs luxurious
eco-friendly mattresses in homes across
America because sattva has no physical
retail stores they're online only they
can offer you a premium mattress at a
fraction of the price without any of the
industry markup tied to commission
middlemen and store front costs
mattresses with comparable specs retail
in stores for well over four times the
amount of money I mean you get a
mattress like sot buzz in store you're
spending four five six grand or more and
Safa it's a fraction of the price I mean
this starts at $8.99 I'm telling you it
is worth doing we've had so many people
and listen
the show right us that they're happy
that they finally did it and that they
invested in themselves and in their
sleep it is worth doing they do not drop
off a box on your on your doorstep that
you're left to unpack like some
companies do these guys actually will
will do old mattress take away for a
small feet this is a luxury product it's
something you find like in a you know
four-star hotel their hypoallergenic
eco-friendly it's simply the best
mattress you can get for the price and
like I said we've been sleeping on it
now for a year and we've never been
happier so easy on the back now and you
get a 75 day in-home trial that's the
other thing I wanted to tell you if
you're wondering oh my god how am I
gonna buy a mattress and I buy online 75
days it's almost three months you're
gonna love it I promise you if you don't
like it you send it back that's not
going to happen so go to satva mattress
comm sa a TV a mattress calm and when
you check out let them know that we sent
you um just you know it will say drop
down menu just hit ymh podcast let him
know we sent you that is all my friends
this is our episode that we recorded a
few weeks ago with our good friend Yoshi
Yoshi's back in the building
it was so fun to have him here there's
never a dull moment with Yosh I hope you
enjoy it
hope you have a great new year and we'll
see you soon bye jeans
welcome to your mom's house
this is a recording yeah we're good all
right Wow Wow
I can't believe you're here it's I don't
think that no one even knows yet it's
kind of probably give them a proper
introduction
thanks for coming today buddy thanks
guys spend too long love doing your show
yeah that we love having you believe me
we gave you a chair I know you're
accustomed to sitting on tatami mats but
we thought you might want a chair this
is perfect it's worth taking three hours
to get here from Russell Peters place in
Malibu three different buses yeah but
listen to that whole sentence from
Russell Russell Peters Malibu pad it's
gorgeous
Oh business just shocking that somebody
that they're that stand-up lived there
you know yeah and is that where he is
that where he's at right now yeah it
must be nice to be talented man talented
and brown and everything men but thinks
about how I'm here this is absolutely
one of my favorite one and people your
fans are unbelievable they're very very
kind very nice of you to invite me to
Thanksgiving weekend where we celebrate
the genocide of a Native American yeah
stomach with their food yeah yeah I
think thank you very much I am very
happy to be here it's been a long time
now we actually tried to get you a
couple weeks ago but you were all really
well yeah well we set this up you were
unavailable until what was it today or
this week because you were you were
doing so oh yeah I'm done that the
medical I mean I'm then I talk about
medical office you did talk about
medical testing but I'd like to get if
it's possible an update as to what your
latest one was this one is Parkinson I
got I want it I can I really don't want
to talk about which company I work
there's like bunch of in Southern
California but this is a really easy one
just you know can't leave for 10 days
then you you're off for three or four
days you go back to another ten and you
know you make 8,500 bucks what do you do
there all day depends on the second in a
day before last day you leave it's a
really long day you literally have to
lay flat on the bed all day why they do
distinguish
action where you have to lay really it's
called supine where you lay flat on the
bed they put this machine order of your
body you can take it out for 24 hours
and you have to completely stay still
still yes for like they record your
heart rate for 5 minutes they want to
know what would your heart rates before
you take any medication and after you
take any medication Jay check your heart
rate to see the difference and that the
one I'm doing is Parkinson and those
days are really really long day
do do you look at anything when you're
laying flat and we can you watch
something okay there's another weird
thing they want you to lay flat but you
cannot go to sleep ah for sure and you
have to look just straight and then like
and you know usually with my eyes I
could kind of fake sleeping they can't
tell if I'm sleeping or not
that's why hm everybody think agents are
good workers but mistakes nap and then
somebody goes are you sleep at all
because my eyes are look like that I'm
not sleeping sir but you can't get away
with that so when you stare at the
ceiling all day yeah and they stand
hover over you make sure you don't go to
sleep wait but God to further that
question again though are you allowed to
watch anything now when you're doing
that I'm you your hands have to be right
next to you straight and there's no
screen you can stare no just looking at
the ceiling Oh for [ __ ] sake one time
I'm obey what are you doing terrible men
now is this I noticed you you got water
and just a side effect of medication
right now maybe in thirsty yeah no but I
have to drink a lot of water because
that way I could have suppress appetite
I'm gonna watch my weight too really
yeah so that you stay healthy to be
available because you know last year
when I was doing it I got a phone call
like hey we have another study but you
have to be BMI of twenty four point nine
nine in other words I have to be one
hundred eighty four point nine or less
and we're waiting what were you waiting
when they call me that one yeah I was
chewy poof so within I think I lost 26
pounds in 25 days where I lost 25 pounds
in 20
six days or whatever and I know I could
do it but is it's it's horrifying
because I'm walking between 15 to 18
miles basically from Santa Monica to
Malibu to Russell's plays you cut down
eating and it was certainly Thanksgiving
last year you know I was hanging out
with my friend Ernie and Chris and
they'll be passing foo front of me but
you can't eat in LA it's a terrible
place because do what every other block
you see homeless person or junk for
restaurants right and it just like it's
I'm I'm really addicted to sugar and
salt
like most Americans I'm the same way I'm
the same way I find that the bigger
challenge is sugar sugar I think is
worse for you
it definitely contributes to weight more
but it's also more addictive yeah yeah
sugar is pretty tough one man the way
when you're doing this this weight
cutting stuff walking all those miles is
your stomach growling throughout this
like these long one I mean actually I do
kind of cheat I for me drinking a lot of
water and coffee really suppress
appetite
mm-hmm but it is hard and like first
couple of days going in like I thought I
did one like 28 days I think my hand
starts shaking because I don't have
caffeine and sugar right but are you
eating nothing like sometimes some of
the medical places are religious
oriented and those are [ __ ] nightmare
because they believe that you shouldn't
take pleasure in food so less salt and
sugar right it's not even necessary that
these farms are medical testing toys
some of these farmers because sometimes
these medical places rent rooms in
hospitals and those hospitals are now
allow certain kinds of food to go to the
hospital
a shockula Chinese Mayo
you're so good so so you know like it's
funny like if you see if you think
there's a bunch of guys in the medical
facility mm-hmm full ex like 20-plus
days you would think guys we're talking
about women all the time
no eventually it's it's food like we all
like you start I mean I'm surfing for
like things I want to eat when I get out
of a thing you know like I knew
something was wrong with it when I cut
myself drawing pictures of food on my
piece of paper not like tits or anything
like that you know dude yeah what so
when you get out do you you go on a huge
binge I mean the worst one was last year
I think I gained like 11 pounds my first
day or something first day what did you
what do you eat what's the first thing
you want when you get out of something
like I eat that ass and [ __ ] all the
time I got nothing I can't even do it
when you get out you can't think you
can't even think about wearing it's that
it's yeah I remember being is not
exactly the same but being have like
food poisoning mm-hmm you know I'm being
in bed for a few days and not eating and
once you get to like that third day of
not eating when it's really bad the
dreams are all food related
like you don't fantasize that anything
but oh man what I'm gonna eat when I
feel better well what do you like though
pizza burger what's your what's your
wish I don't know why I always think
about you need a burger so that's good
in the place I'm staying right now it's
right well like a block away so like
that's like the you know but I've been
pretty good even the first night it's
not that I went gangway I'm just worried
about Nick studies I don't really want
to go torture losing way so I'm trying
to smart control better but it's not
that easy you know but relatively
speaking this study it's pretty good and
what I've been doing is I've read a lot
of stuff about you know history medical
testing and somebody was pretty
horrendous and they had the
studied did I tell you that one time hey
I don't know why they did this there I
tell you guys that they one experiment
they put [ __ ] people in freezer
did I tell you that one yes yes you
mentioned this okay it sounds familiar
so I know you mentioned it before you
know Japanese did all kinds of horrible
stuff into reward sure in Germans too
and we we did too but I've been doing
this a couple years I have to say I
really do have a lot of respectful
people Medical feel
I mean it's supporting honorable
profession pure and I think for most
part except for the one place that I've
ripped me off I think they really wanted
to find cure for too many of these
problems you know so there's last one
you did it's a Parkinson's you were
taking retaking pills every day or
getting my agent yeah just up every day
they take your blood they you know they
do your vitals they want to know you
know they hook you up an EKG and figure
out your blood pressures or any heart
rates and things like that and what I
like about is like I've been I've been
learning a lot of our medical stuff last
couple years and here so I have a lot of
questions and most of the guys they
don't really give a [ __ ] and I was kind
of like that too but I get really bored
so I had to keep I have to do something
mentally occupying so what are you like
do you spend I'm curious about this too
do you spend let's say free time do you
get to read King my every shitload of
magazines and books I've been working a
couple of things too so it's it's nice
to have a free time to do that yeah hey
did you say there was another test that
you were getting spinal injections said
that one that was too horrendous one
that was the one before that that was
August September and first week October
staying in a facility it's the same
place again this one so the reason I
picked this one there was a two studies
available right right and I've I qualify
for the both of the studies now I picked
the one with the spinal cord in jek ssin
because I thought it's funny I thought
it was funny to get shot in your spinal
cord
yeah and because I I like every time I
read those documents
keywords like southern death or
something horrible that could happen to
you yeah I kind of preferred those over
the regular one because you get paid
more yeah but other one was easier and
it's five grand and the one I did was
7,500 but the funny thing was the people
who did that easier one within a couple
days they had orange spots everywhere in
their body their face legs and so
something really went wrong so yeah
they'd eventually stop and add in insult
to injury they got deducted thousand
dollars because they can continue to
study you would think they're a ghen
izing pain and their face yeah like
that's amber bronco uniform that's so
[ __ ] up that it doesn't go well so
they have to discontinue and then they
get paid acht yes that's crazy well I
noticed that you've got a bit of a cough
now do you think that could be a side
effect I've always said cough come from
when I was you know radiation so third
day of going in there ready to get
spinal cord thing right and like all
right so I'm room way with this guy he's
first I'm the second guy to get it
so he's 5:45 a.m. a doctor comes in
right so first he make that guy I'm kind
of watching peripheral vision so I'm
watching him so he make that guy set in
the edge of the bed with his t-shirt up
kind of bent over why because you have a
spinal cord right so when you bend
they'll find the gap between all the
bones so he's gonna find wherever's have
the biggest gap between the two bones
then if you put this big red circle
around it mm-hmm they're wrong the pot
spot you're gonna put the needle he'll
put four or five different novocaine
shots right or something similar to
novocaine to numb the area right oh my
god then I kind of look peripheral
vision yes in the nurse breath this
big-ass needle and she's kind of
clicking where you see a little bit of
liquid coming down it's a because if I
can eat her right
and the doctor goes you know it's like
it won't hurt whatever right so okay I'm
going to go in so he do it right and the
thing like that's just a meat I've been
before and the guy getting the need oh
he goes he's like oh is that a kid I
don't wanna [ __ ] hear that's you know
by 45662 am like I don't want to they
told me it's not that painful you know
salesmanship like oh my god I can't look
and it goes like okay 15% 20% like maybe
two hundred two and a half minutes or
three minutes of fun either done right
but like he's gonna make this noise for
two minutes
yeah and like oh my god and weren't you
scared were you scared when it was your
turn yeah but I mean I I needed the
money to get passports I could go Europe
prostitute this and dad you know you
have your priorities so did you have did
you even have a thought of like I
shouldn't [ __ ] do this uh like when
that guy it's not gonna I thought maybe
I could just run out of there oh yeah of
course yeah of course but then again how
do you fight that instinct Yoshi of
self-preservation sorry I wasn't
thinking yeah well I got vasectomy so I
thought it can be more painful that than
that is that painful
oh my god yeah wait I thought that's the
whole thing that advertises that you
know
it's the technology is so good it's just
I got it like years ago like ninety uh
okay that's old this is the whole story
for me but I guess I never told you guys
so it's so my ate my turn so when you
have epidural shot great wait can we ask
you this real quick yeah I want you to
continuous for sure but what is this
testing for this one was Alzheimer the
spinal injection yeah they want to know
yo level before taking the medication
and afterwards so they have to do two
spine to spinal cord shots please I'm
gonna give birth in two weeks I don't
need to hear this man you have to lay
flat because you get epidural shot
headache and it's supposed to be bad
what was so funny after I got mine I was
the only kid then then have a headache
because I always have [ __ ] headache
so I couldn't tell the difference you
got a lay flat and like the guy tried to
get up he got hit it but I got up and I
didn't have I didn't feel you know so
after the shutter I didn't feel anything
but so it was my turn and like did the
same thing bent over rest circle never
can't stop and like I didn't I didn't
really like it but like I don't [ __ ]
don't like it it's like when my
ex-girlfriend trying to put finger in my
ass that yeah I don't like it but I
think I have a higher threshold pain
than that guy that sounds like it so the
but that wasn't the worst part for that
study
it wasn't no diverse study the worst
part of that study is that medication
may cause some retina damage so we have
to go see hi doctor and there's seven
Asian people and to like one black one
one one one black one white guy you mean
working there for the studies Oh for the
study okay well a lot of Asians huh so
well because Asians think we are the
best at metabolizing medication any
other race really so we get in our blood
sister
quicker than anyone and we could get it
rid of it better than anyone no way you
know how do white people fare like
weren't worried why people fall on that
so you guys are pretty good but we're so
much faster than any other race so and
but even within the Asian people like
they had like maybe a bunch of people
but I always select it sometimes when my
blood is compatible for this job I
didn't know you know you have super
blood from all the hookers
oh definitely we have all fine it's
called HIV let's gonna say you've
probably jockeys disease you've battled
HIV you probably beaten it so we get eye
examination right mm-hmm oh no man
there's a seven or eight tests that we
have to do and they have to scan your
eye and go they have trouble getting in
there and I go there to pull well they
keep saying like sir you need to keep
your eyes wide open it is sir I'm aging
like I can't make it my eyes and you
bigger so like they're getting so angry
with me because that pista usually take
half an hour it takes about two hours
and trying to have hours for me no way
they're so mad and like because every
time they scan they can't do it and I
keeping my eyes as wide as I can it's
just not good enough so a few times at
this Armenian doctor right he have to
literally come behind me put two of his
fingers keep my eyes wide open like so I
was right like clockwork mandarin orange
yes yes yeah and then and they're mad
because why can't you keep your eyes
wide well first of all you're Armenian
you guys used to your odor and it
doesn't do [ __ ] you smell like dogs
[ __ ] we all have weakness sir so we
fight every time I get exhibit like
every time they see me and out of the
Asian group I was always the worst one -
they [ __ ] hate team oh my god like
they have to keep redoing the test over
and over there's one way you look at
straight the right light and have a
clicker and every time I see a red spot
I gotta click it but sometimes the red
light is very faint so I can't it's not
really red and sometime I fail the test
so I have to keep doing I [ __ ] pass
that
mmm-hmm another one's like the bright
lights can you eyes oh my god and
there's another one you see a blue cross
and you gotta look at straight across
where they hit they have this bright
light going up and down like I'm having
a hard time keeping it gets so bright
and [ __ ] mates like I torture but every
time I go they're like oh they're there
they have this look like oh my god this
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah but I have to
do it because I won't get paid you know
so you get you took longer than the
basically everybody to get through their
first in the last person go home and
I've still have to wait another 45 Oh an
hour so did you have any retina damage
no no okay it happened when they you
know like like most studies they do it
on animal but then some animals they
found that retina damages you know well
let me ask you this but about your
vasectomy is the most painful part the
actual procedure or afterwards like
recovery man doubt that the procedure
hurt like a [ __ ]
really yeah because now it's supposed to
be like laser incision and like some
people even say like they could do one
with water pressure I know that I know a
friend that had one done and he said
that you know he was talking to the
doctor like about football game during
it yeah and then it was just like you're
all right you can go you're done Yoshi
had his in 95 that's I think that's the
big difference I got three four shots
each testicles and then he'll cut
incision inside of the ball and I don't
know what's I don't know what was kinda
know what's going on but it's almost
like cutting a really cheap meat that
you but it's not like a Kobe beef dude
going back and forth right and there's
blood everywhere and one Pullman where
did you get this you have one of the
hookers do it or nobody made me go to a
doctor I was working a compass in
America I'm I was working at the company
and they're ready to file for bankruptcy
so I know I was getting fired and my
insurance was still good and I was I
don't really want to go in detail but
there's a reason why I wanted to get it
done but I'm gonna lose insurance you
might as well do this now so I went and
man it hurt like a [ __ ] in the
heat is climbing back and forth then
what and and this is like I I did have
to work so like there's phone call he
leaves middle of the operation go to the
office answer the phone like I'm there
with my dick open with blood everywhere
I think kind of laugh as I can I know
you didn't go to a good place you know
then eventually he'll pull all this
white thing got it there clip it yeah
and you know how the magician have the
trick like out of the pocket green
yellow purple whatever lying yeah he's
pulling all that [ __ ] of my dick
testicles put everything together put it
back and trying to close the cut with
this little flare and he's burning the
side of my balls and you literally
smoking me out of my balls
that was my primitive vasectomy which
kind of little medical app thing because
they're always worried about while
taking this medication I getting
somebody pregnant well that's not gonna
yeah so that's another reason I'm a good
candidate now let's get to UM you said
we can tell our listeners that you're
going to be abroad soon they could they
could even come meet you somewhere yeah
so so I've been putting lucky last four
months I did this two big studies may
very lucky a lot of money so I was able
to pay my tax gave my passport and
during that's Friday the 13 couple weeks
ago uh-huh attack in Paris like I start
trying booking a flight to Belgium and
France and Morocco because most of those
problem in friends and Belgium is
Moroccan you know and I have no fear of
brown people I meant play Moroccan
people 99.9% of are not a terrorist and
I like those people but and what are the
funds to is that you should find a great
I mean it's one of the you know it's
it's awful obviously what happened and
the it affects tourism greatly but then
it also it's cheap now that's so saying
time to go to those places yeah to get
great deals and and and and it's always
interesting to me that whenever there's
been like a terrorist attack I should be
laughing but they're always close by a
red-light district so I'll do my amateur
detective terrorist [ __ ] like usual but
nighttime I go see hookers at night
times that's and that's half of the trip
other half I have think I've shown
Belfast Dublin Netherlands and I think
few shows in Stockholm that's great and
and how could people find out when and
like you know I'm still waiting for the
response but like I don't have the dates
yet alright but that you will post them
what on Twitter probably Twitter and
Facebook yeah okay what's your Twitter
handle so people know Oh Yoshi obayashi
I should get something easier but Yoshi
obayashi obayashi Oh be a why a si J you
guys unbelievable I speak that my super
white people um you also mentioned that
I think when you're in Germany
um you talking about that the porno
thing yeah okay so I'm only offering
this to your mom's house because you
guys have been so supportive
yeah don't get me wrong I mean you know
Joe Rogan talking [ __ ] all those guys
are nice to you but um um so there's a
there's a listener it's a very special
place in the the beautiful guppies that
listen to the show that in their their
hearts for you your favorite before
wonderful with you guys and Ike I love
Joe Rogan you know Joe is great but
sometimes he used those big words and
scientifically terms your honor me lying
yeah I don't want to pretend like I know
what he's talking about but with you
guys I could talk about [ __ ] my
pants those type of big words aren't
really the type that you hear around
here it's a totally it's a different
type you know so but with with us you're
not gonna have that so I don't know how
to do this because maybe I need to
figure out ways to raise money or
something
so so I've been kind of thinking like
big words I was thinking like maybe
doing like a la vi tour where I have a
van and I would drive people in LA like
okay
in this place this and this thing happy
at the elegant angel porn where a guy
got murdered for blah blah blah like
driver on LA with a great idea great
idea I would say give a sex tour where
guys can get Handy's like which massage
parlors they can go to won't get the
best I'm not really that knowledgeable
but like I know what's your I got like a
porn issue like you know this is where
Wonderland murder where John Holmes has
something to do with you know a murder
this and this is where one of the poor
girl got murdered supposedly like
throughout the valley and la oh Black
Dahlia Murder and things like that but
the one I'm working on is one in
hopefully in Germany like your mom's
fans if we could pick up the dates and
if we get enough people I could tell
them like we could go first three days
in the red light district in Amsterdam
take a train to Berlin
great idea but if you want to see a girl
guys [ __ ] on each other right here
so I'm not frame with this guy Brandon
Irons live in Dublin and if your friend
implanted in iron he's looking for
regular Java Dublin so please help him
but his friend with a guy named John
Thompson one of the biggest porn guy in
Germany he does this thing called GGG
which is German gue girls and the best
[ __ ] German
it's a lot of [ __ ] yeah it's yeah
it's invented [ __ ] right yes [ __ ]
literally means not enough to spread so
it's it's actually food like you have
this of dry frying noodles you put a
little bit of sauce on top you tried to
spread across the noodle but the term
another term is this is a long time it
goes something Horrible's mean does
something horrible in the village
cheating on her husband or something
everyone in the village would take that
women away from the village middle of
nowhere they would take time ejaculating
order of her phase out of shame she will
cure herself in America you get chick
for $2,000 big difference right by the
German - German Japanese and germans
this is pretty [ __ ] okay what i'm
seeing is these two girls are like are
blowing this guy well two of them are
blowing them one of the girls getting
[ __ ] within another guy is pissing on
all of them yeah including the guy that
they're blowing yeah so he's getting
pissed on his dick is getting pissed on
by another guy yeah as they blow him
when they get [ __ ] teamwork so
complicated yeah that is teamwork and
this is a this is your guide jog with
him john thompson john thompson and his
go girl stuff when these guys are peeing
so much so April 16th June 11th April 16
my birthday well in Bremen Germany if
you have a you get your test in e or
you're a clean you can go and show up
and get your dick sock or I didn't
realize we're putting that out there -
Wow or if you don't want to do that you
just wanna stand in and watch you have
to pay 250 euro to be watching it but if
you if you you know I could help you
with that
and I also could take you to different
parts of Europe it just depends on them
you have to get some how will you be the
liaison cuz your connections you'll be
able to like hook this up yeah Wow and I
and if they raise enough money we
show you different places of red-light
district and Amsterdam
that would be cool Alex my Netherlands
that is Milken we were talking about
this a little bit is that you really
know the ins and outs of the red light
district in Amsterdam I know enough and
I know I got ripped off over the years I
know how to avoid it so tell us what's a
good what's a tip a Yoshi not getting
ripped off and am one of them without
giving away all your most part the girls
are pretty funny word to use honorable
but a place is like Amsterdam's little
tricky because it's a touristy town a
lot of the girls knows most likely
you're going to use our service once
there there are more inclined you kind
of rip off oh because you're one and
done yeah you're not gonna come back but
if you're in the other smaller towns
they figure well I like to have a client
right a regular yeah and assuming that
girls pretty honest you just tell her
exactly what you want then she'll say
well if you want to do X and X Y & Z
it's gonna cost this much money and
always be respectful when she give you a
good service always those tipped a girl
what's a good tip I always worry about
tips and you know life and travels you
don't know do I tip is a good tip ten
boxes of twenties is it if it's fifty
year old you know if you're getting a
girl in the Amsterdam fifty year old and
it was five to ten euros should be fine
they don't expect it but it's nice to do
that
another thing even if you don't mean an
IKE thank you very much are you gonna be
here tomorrow you know before you have
sex that kind of plea incentive or in
your head like well you might be coming
back tomorrow oh that's a real good tip
that's so 50 euro and what do you get
for that
most places like Frankfurt is 30 I've
seen as it louis toady to twenty
five-year-old you're going to go there
Alec Mars 30 in Netherlands but 50 is
probably like the you know big Amsterdam
Belgium Brussels and that includes what
in in 50 most most between 50 to 20
minutes and [ __ ] suck so cheap for
this so cheap but that's what happened
when you legalize something like that
where you have more competition the
reason it's so high over here is illegal
so you're taking arrest she's taking
arrest and she had to make it worth her
while but I have to say the quality is
way higher when it's legalized because
just whenever there's competition the
quality goes up goes up yeah you
mentioned your friend Brandon iron is in
Ireland yeah
and is that why you're going is that
what you're you say aren't you going to
Ireland or no yeah I'm going like maybe
90 different countries but I'm visiting
Dublin to visit Brandon but I'm also fan
of James Joyce and Oscar Wilde so I want
to go Trinity College and check that
stuff there and your friend a brand is
looking for a job yeah a legit job yeah
I mean he got this girl pregnant he went
he went to get out of the business and
take care of the kid he you know he's
his honor
I mean he's not one of the reason why
also Brandon was he should have made
more money in the business but that that
business for was come back and and
Brandon's choose honest into honorable
and it's really hard to compete with
those kind of slimeball in the business
but he always tried to do the right
thing and I've known him a long time
he's a very honest guy so he's looking
for work but you know it's a Catholic
country they're really hard ass like you
can't get apartment unless you and your
girlfriend a marry you know what oh yeah
there's mansion in Ireland yeah yeah
they just finally legalized abortion
within the last six seven eight years
now but I mean as a porno guy how would
you rank him as a performer one of the
greats
he's he's got one of those we're
combination because if you wanted those
guys has a huge dick you don't do
anything creative right yeah for example
if you're Clemson Alabama do you speak
football program sure you have all the
biggest talent you don't really have to
do [ __ ] because you have big talent you
just put them in the right spot but when
you have a small colleges you don't have
as many
talented players you have to do all
these kind of internet you know they've
creative stuff that other B colleges
were big talents they don't have to do
it right branding no-name a big dick and
who [ __ ] really well but he does all
this crit like his family's his famous
as mister slap-happy where he slapped
girls
Ramar that was at one of his moves yeah
but he only does it with the girls who
are into it you know what I mean all
right yeah not a surprise distinction
yeah so he's but like a like an Oregon
football team if you will like they have
a lot of town but they're also very
creative with their innovations that
yeah boring happen is he a strong
performer or yeah you say strong he
[ __ ] really hard he seemed too rough
sense yeah yeah but he think he's the
worst he's what he's almost kind of
round me David tell a porn you don't
like but he doesn't think he does a
great job but it's never good enough I
mean what what would be like his
critique of himself like I I didn't [ __ ]
her hard enough or yeah I think he's
underrated he should be no Fame wow he
sees and he's his interest he did this
in call intensity in ten cities so he
[ __ ] different girls in 10 different
cities of the world but before he [ __ ]
any other girls he would take each girl
kind of check out the city and like
history of you know something happy at
this building and it's very creative
yeah then they have nice meal the hill
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of her
so the you know he did a lot of
interesting stuff but stuff like that
doesn't sell well it's always like
slapping occur over the car or this and
that that you know make some money you
know but yeah yeah check out Brandon are
calm he's great alright my life Yoshi is
so besides that also if yeah if they're
a fandom I don't want to do and if I get
enough people really serious about doing
something like that
just email I think two of your ideas
both of these are worth pursuing
one is la-based yeah it's a great idea
yeah creative put together interesting
sex tour that doesn't necessarily mean
sex is a part of it but like sex history
sex right
sure all that stuff really good idea and
I think the European one yeah your mom's
house presents blah blah blah yeah but
like where you were you a guide somebody
a guide is it helpful in any situation
so having like the guide there yeah to
tell you like this is a good place to go
this is how you should approach this is
kind of money you shouldn't valuable
it's a huge service if you can do that
and eventually I would like to do other
things like for ladies too you know
because the most most it's interesting a
lot of the women goes to Caribbean and
African countries I'm sorry where
Caribbean which African countries I
think Nigeria but that doesn't like
mature English a lot of English women
I'm all for that because you know these
women they have they have their own
needs they have six you're free you know
and they work really hard yeah why not
you vent divorce your kids grow up and
gone to college you did everything right
why Knight 455 you're having hard time
dating you go Trinidad you get 90 no
black boy why not why not you know good
for you get your groove back now whose
dirty and disgusting where's your
favorite place to for hookers where do
you what's your Mecca I know I know what
it is I tell you but I guess yeah it's
Frankfurt that's one of my favorite ones
but you know I have to say in Brazil
it's it's a different animal see last
time you were towards German and now
it's Brazil you mention what you're
looking for because hard [ __ ] core
the DOS Brazilian women they it's I
don't know I don't know if prostitution
is right because they are prostitutes
but sometimes they want to just hang out
with you for the week and they just
women going to be taking care of it and
they're very very sweet the Brazilians
yeah
I don't necessarily say most of women
who does prostitution
of Europe necessary does messenger [ __ ]
or anything it just it's work for them
it's more transactional it sounds like
sure as you're saying in Brazil you
could meet some girl let's say online
beforehand and you show up and you meet
her what is that oh you could be at the
beach and then eating and then she just
started talking to someone okay
they could be from favela they just want
to go to nice place with actually hot
shower go to movie and like the you know
date the things that you take care for
granted they don't have and and quite
often these guys you know like buy stuff
for them you know like to me if you're a
doe and you're a more emphasized now be
respectful to this girl yeah you keep
saying that be respectful and always
always tip if they're getting good
service and take a bath for God's sake I
don't know I'm tank or strip club and
like these girls are working really hard
you know don't women are super sensitive
with smell they're really good with
their nose and like you know just to do
some prep work you know it's almost like
pagan the religion you respect these
women you know what I mean yeah I think
you should legalize it and protect the
women that are sex workers it's not a
perfect solution but it's better than
other happening yeah I agree
so you go to Brazil and like you kind of
you kind of wife this girl up for like a
week or two in other words like you take
her to dinners but the approach I think
the approach we have to go dude first
the approach could be literally just
sitting there you're sitting there
having lunch somewhere yeah I mean I've
only been there once but I went to we
were saying Copacabana there's a place
they used to go help and literally
there's like for every guy there's like
20 women there and that's one of the few
places like if you if you're a regular
guy you feel like rocks are because they
were literally rush up to you and just
grab your dick we gotta go
it's called house you're not going so
Kobe could you go there and then this
girls come up to you and like talking to
you maybe you know what are you doing
here you're staying in town for a while
and then you you picked you pick the one
you like basically sure and you hang out
with her for I think I mean I wasn't
there if that long by like Jim Norton
and Patrice O'Neal used to talk about
that
but but Jim didn't he also liked the
transsexuals
there's no I'm sure yeah yeah I mean I
that's what I've heard
yeah so have you ever been with a
transsexual is that your bag no I have I
haven't I get that asked live like it I
mean hey I I have not but I have to say
I have a half whole lot of girlfriends
but it's shocking few of the [ __ ] is
I'm in Brazil like they're just so
beautiful you can't believe it's it's
it's a guy yeah
but what I don't understand that there's
one said that it's so obvious you're a
man and I don't find it attractive like
if the person looked like a woman like
what can you say like he's got a dick
she's got a dick but it's just beautiful
but there's other ones like it's
obviously a guy you know six foot two
black guy you know but some some guys
that are into that you know that's
that's just now well I imagine it's
confusing to your reptilian brain
because you're like all this tricks so
hot and then she's got a painter like
it's just I imagine conflicting for men
conflicting but I think this might be
there's a scientific explanation but my
unscientific explanation is and this is
something Jim Norton it's just
incredible in the honest like he usually
makes me so uncomfortable because Jim is
the absolutely the most honest comic
that I have ever met yeah honest guy
period but I think men in general always
affray called the c-word to creep right
being judged by women and when you when
you dealing with the transgender person
technically violet I mean technically
that person is man so they understand
the urges that they have but because
they're taking female hormone and they
identified themselves a woman they could
sympathize with that person you know and
it's it's it's that part that I find it
so interesting that they just want to be
not treated horribly you know of course
it's empathy if you have any you know
yeah but they are basically are also
more
and to as many piggish things as you
want to do yeah because they understand
right yeah so it sounds like to me the
best of both worlds is a transgender
yeah why why not in my opinion you're
going there like why not I don't know
you have to think of the opposite I'm
trying to think of like a dude who has a
vision like would that appeal to me I
don't know I think the interesting part
to me also is the aspect of hanging out
like for a week with somebody it's way
different than the transactional right
yeah it sounds a bit nicer it's a bit
nicer it sounds like and I can't
remember which Italian automobile
company it's a big one it runs by this
very famous a very powerful family in
Italy and their son or grandson who
won't one day take over the country I
remember five seven years ago they found
his body
OD they saved this life but he was
hanging out with like three or four
different females in Rome and I don't
necessarily think it it could be a
sexual thing but it's also she a
transgender people are very wise they
they're they understand how men thinks
and also women think the creek called
Tiresias remember that mythological myth
Tiresias did something horrible to upset
the gods so God punished high racers and
turn him into a woman for seven days
seven years and I don't know what
happened maybe he did something good
where God may her back to a man but
after that even God's that he was the
wisest of all because he understand what
men and women think even the Greek gods
remember Zeus and Hera his wife they're
always fighting in marital even the gods
who have a marital problem Tiresias was
the why so I mean I'm comfortable run
there because I worked in porn force all
I met a lot of him but it's a mate I
can't even imagine 12 years ago with
Caitlyn Jenner and and all this
transparent that show and like there's
really like incredible amount of changes
in last 12 years yeah
yeah I think no matter who you with you
got to remember that towels can have
AIDS
yes have you ever gone to the
Philippines and on hookers no I have not
are you attracted Asian women yeah okay
I don't know about Asian American women
but I like Asian women okay
there's a that's a different animals I
think you know I my family is not my my
family don't like to talk about it but
my neighborhood when I was grow up in
Japan within a mile and a half two miles
was very similar to red light district
in Amsterdam you have all this homes
right next to each other the front gate
is open you see a girl I'm tatami floor
and kind of sitting there with this
really old lady sitting next to her and
you negotiate the old lady if you want
to have sex with her
I grew up in that I mean that was like
within a mile and a half where I grew up
so I thought that's like normal sex
business is normal you know I didn't
realize how big a deal it wasn't you
moved here because I didn't grow what's
religion either so it's a very bizarre
but I you know I grow with that sort of
thing so I I think it's so weird that
sex is such a normal thing and I don't
know why guys are called program when
it's natural that we we desire women and
think about it all the time but it's
it's really weird judging people for the
thing that is so normal things that we
desire agree you know I agree about that
so absolutely you know you're very lucky
because your life is beautiful
intelligent and well minded and very
often act awful minded I'm gonna go to
Brazil before the baby's born Thailand
have you done prostitutes there I've
only been to South Korea and Japan I
haven't been in Asia but you see girls
are you heard of juicy girls in South
Korea no okay
when I was on the north and military
bases there the the prostitutes were
called juicy girls they're usually
nearby military bases right yeah yeah so
I I would like to
visit I just have to be careful because
I have Japanese name and you know what
they did during World War 2 I don't ever
want to be with a non Japanese girl
where I said I'm just fearful of that
you know people know yeah so what do you
think the difference is between Asian
American girls and just asian asian
girls because you're saying you prefer
asian asian i'm not saying it's
impossible not like an asian american
girls but um what's up what do you think
the big difference is you know who with
the japanese girl that new ones and
subtle things that they do a kind of
like that and it's kind of like you know
the food that you grow up with you could
you kind of pretty much judge everything
else based on what you grow up yeah so
obviously I grew up with Japanese girls
and women and I guess I guess I do
prefer to it's not like dominating than
that I'm just not into that sort of
things but I don't know I just like
they're the temperament is I like that
ever man better Japanese yeah Japanese
girls yeah they laugh a lot and stuff
like they giggle on stuff but they're
now weak are either that's a thing that
they don't understand
no absolutely the Asian women are not
weak I mean they rule the roost as far
as I could tell like when I had the
Chinese boyfriend I know it's not the
same as Japanese but his mom ran the
show
I'm not into this streamer Japanese
girls don't have to scream to hit they
just have a really clever subtle way
like they would never tell you what they
like oh they'll never tell you what they
hey
did she like it or hate it yeah how do
you know what did she like it or hate it
what she was doing your son it's not a
Japanese girl yeah was yeah she spoke
English though she learned a couple
words oh so wait a Japanese girl I don't
like that Pony [ __ ] at all you know
you're saying she won't tell you if you
likes or hates anything in I'm each
death that's traditionally cuz if people
knew what you like they're gonna try to
take it away because you're a woman
and if you like if you want if you see
if you if you hey if you dislike
something you don't let her know because
that's what they might do to you so with
the Japanese women it's a new ones then
and it's very challenging it's it's
sorry football reference it's like the
relationship between quarterback and
defensive back quarterback you know he
knows that he's been watched by
defensive back right defensive back know
that he's being watched they're trying
to outsmart each other right that's the
kind of [ __ ] that lineage and they pick
up on each other tendency and yes like
that so that's a that's like a
relationship with a Japanese girl I mean
that's that's the kind of stuff I notice
really so that's what you like in dating
yeah and we're dating you would like to
date a Japanese yeah it's really funny
talking to them but you want to date
like Japanese I don't I don't know if I
want to date anyone no but I'm saying it
wouldn't intrigue you to do it today to
Japanese American could be Japanese
they're just so I mean that's like a
difference between Africa and black
person that it's a we're all difference
yeah one say yo and the other ones
saying right the huge difference kind of
maybe I'm the black guy right cuz I go
though that I think so you know the
black people in Scandinavia they act so
tough I'm like come on you're a born in
Sweden you speak four languages you have
health insurance you you don't you have
you have virtually no chance getting
shot by cops and you listen to American
rap act like black American like yeah
it's it's
so funny they they act like that and
when I go to those this is the worst
never don't go there like it's a [ __ ]
joke I'm the new girl you know I'm
saying that when I go to those places
now so this is in you go to Scandinavia
yeah because now we're gonna speak the
language of Christina sure lion like if
you're into Craig are if you're into
camu all the extensional stuff yeah the
bleakness but they're fantastic because
I leave there's a place for depression
and scene negativity yeah because during
an emergency they're they don't panic
because they're all there
there used to seem bleak that's right
that's what I always tell my husband is
that I'm not the best during a crisis
that's why my brains already wired for
darkness so when bad things happen it
just feels like home oh my god I'm
prepared for this actually that's
absolutely true because some historian
said Lincoln suffer from terrible
depression but because he's so used to
the depression he could deal with the
terrible time
that's why Scandinavians really fun to
do shows for them because you could talk
some really dark [ __ ] they just laugh
it's like an AAA room you ever done an
AAA room yeah they get dark as [ __ ]
they're the best you can say whatever
you want in a room so dark sex can in
every trait but if you go to southern
region people are more sunny I I do not
do very well in those rooms
even though am I gonna offer to work a
month in Hawaii but it's gotta be clean
show a guy named Artie but I don't I
don't mind if it's Hawaii or whatever
and it's no [ __ ] fun he shows the
worst it really is I [ __ ] want to
blow my brains out on furniture I don't
even have clean material for an hour do
you I don't want to talk about I used to
be able to really script it out if I got
booked for something in private and I
just gotta clean I would I would take my
notebook right out like first we'll
figure out all my material yeah and then
like put like lines next to clean or
then I'd try it it's kind of a good
workshop thing yeah cuz there you go hey
could I make this one
I mean you know like hey you know
choking on my jizz or like the [ __ ]
ain't like that stuff's all out but then
you go well this thing maybe I could
make this work if I if I a lot of
insinuation you know you don't want to
draw dirty picture but yeah I actually
Auggie T is a big TV personality a radio
person Hawaiian eye open for him and it
was really funny cuz I'd really tone it
down by know a lot of Hawaiian
references I did a show at church for
Hawaiian people you know and they'll
love that you and that's hard I know I
was even shocked but like they did they
choose a Christ I believe I didn't set
on fire I was surprised myself you know
like I kind of Tong I mean it's diluted
like the way you put kimchi in the water
Inbal for water right but yeah it was a
really good exercise that's not
something I want to do all the time but
I'll be right if some you can do it for
a little bit I mean you know 15 minutes
from the Augie tea order yeah and it's
just a bummer to get asked I feel that I
got I hate their like can you do this
clean like dude you know why because it
takes the adult fun out of doing it's
like listen if you're all consenting
adults why do I have to act like we're
children I think it's it's juveniles
childish it's like this that pregnancy
thing I have a stupid app and it sends
you updates and one of the things the
question was will I pass stool while I'm
in labor passing stool like you can't
even [ __ ] say will I take a dump on
the table like we're so childish we
can't even call it what it is now by the
way speaking of do labor and whatnot
[ __ ] out of here I'm pretty excited that
you're gonna be lactating soon and one
of the fetishes adult breastfeeding in
this couple here is it really yeah for
sure
the guy's real fixated on how long he
can keep his wife lactating stays
lactating and hopefully I can keep a
lactating
being lactating in 20 years I mean
that's possible I think Jeff and
Michelle are gonna be in for some rude
awakenings down the road and I would
certainly encourage Jeff and Michelle to
seek further counseling to explore these
issues oh she sees it a TV that's up
there I'm concerned there's not really
any need to consult the therapist
further about the fetishes because it's
not really harmful well here the videos
are for Michelle and I are hopefully
we'll have a big family now he will only
wants a big family
so that she keeps lactating eight kids
notice she goes I do want to have
another child and he's like maybe we'll
have eight kids he just wants to keep
second on those titties but what's our
ginger what you um like sexual appetite
is it different when you're pregnant or
just the same or if they it fluctuates
you know some months you're it depends
on you here what your body's doing also
depends person-to-person we we know yeah
we know couples we're like the woman
shuts it down
yeah no no then there's hyper sexual and
then there's pigs like us right baby
sounds yeah I mean you know I I think
we've just maintained a normal healthy
so cool you know
yeah it just depends on your warrior
sometimes you're in pain yeah you know
and you're just like uh then sometimes
you feel like a normal person so but
different strokes every woman is
different yeah I don't know how much
time do you have left for this one I
just need to mint once and one thing
that that we had we got time by the way
okay good good you don't might talk
about this right now what we're talking
about okay I'm scared oh no this is
actual act a ting no no no it has
nothing to do with it so I don't know
when I'll be out of the country in
January but my friend I go gunderson
we're gonna be releasing a magazine
called illegal magazine in San Francisco
well you're gonna be releasing any legal
magazine
no that's the name of the okay okay
Kalia legal magazines and this magazine
and program was started in in Copenhagen
Denmark by a guy named Mike Olsen he's a
social entrepreneur so these magazines
are sold by addicts in Copenhagen and
many of the article pictures and
artworks are done by addicts and former
addicts and basically every time they
sell these magazine they keep 40% and
they use that money to buy drugs so they
don't have to prostitute themselves and
commit petty crimes and it's been going
for a while and Michael started this
program where he's driving a van with a
doctor nurse pick up an addict and let
them in check heroin back so prevent
overdose so what happened was he used to
help Romanian kids homeless kids in 80s
and 90s when he came back to Copenhagen
he noticed there all this syringes in
his neighborhood he started talking to
addicts and he thought he really need to
help these people in Copenhagen and for
a long time the government was against
it but they implement a program after
all because it was saving a lot of
people people's lives so cities and
driving around picking up people too you
know I am NOT suggesting drugs are good
for you I prefer that you don't do it if
you do it I consider as a medical issue
and I don't think you're a bad person
and we want to you know help you but he
also facility where people fix meals
place to write their business plan and
get job skills and help them get out of
the transition from an addict oh and
there's another one drug use a union a
guy named mr. Jurgen we've been kind of
working to help people with drug issues
and they implement this program in
London too so now we're gonna release
this magazine hopefully in sometime in
January we're you know trying to raise
money and help people with acute issues
you know because I was friend with Mitch
Hedberg and I love the guy and makes me
sad you know it's been a little over ten
years this year that he passed away and
we we have tons of friends who in comedy
you know
Harris widows you know I only hit him
once but just insane that we keep doing
this drug war and
throwing people in jail where they
needed medical help not in jail you know
so well in the Netherlands that don't
they give out heroin and clean needles
yeah but they're not compromised you
know their health is a compromise they
don't have to rob people sure it's
actually like if you're gonna be an
addict when the Netherlands is a great
place to be in Germany I think in
Frankfurt derecho pumped room where you
go all the addicts are going in and
there's a clean room to put in heroin
and then clean needles to prevent spread
of STD and I you know it's one of those
pet peeves I have a long time I don't
like the drug war which is misleading
because war eventually end and this is
you know this thing's been going a long
time so you know if you if you have idea
for articles so you have an artwork for
this magazine you know you could dumb
Yoshi at gmail.com or Facebook or
Twitter account but yeah we were trying
to raise money get this thing out
what would you know the content of this
magazine will be right now we have the
first issue we have like former addicts
you know what was like growing up in New
York City it just depends on the addict
or former addicts writing are anything
to do with drug-related yeah articles
but but any fun content or just all
bummers about being something fun like
we have sometimes comedians rounded but
you know when I think we might try to
get Jason rouse another funny comedian
writer Arden yeah but I could write an
article about when I od'd all that we
would we've a lot I didn't I didn't know
I didn't know that yeah I mean serious
yeah
I did when I was 19 oh we would love to
have you write something you know yeah
sure it's it'll be the first North
American issue of illegal magazine I'd
love to and if you want to read about
illegal magazine there's been couple
Clips on Vice you know so okay yeah
that's it it makes me feel sad to see
these people are getting punished I even
met Campbell and Douglas Michael Douglas
son through one of my friend ten years
ago New York City and he was a seem like
a wonderful person we talked about
politic but he said he's still alive
he's in jail they just add another
like crazy many years in a sense sense
because they found the drugs with him
like look he's being punished
he needs rugs these are like people that
needs medical attention he'll put it
yeah makes absolutely no sense so and um
yeah it's it and all the black young
african-american kids we're waiting
years of their lives always with the
drug related stuff you know it's great
if they're not violent criminal get n
rape anyone then put in the info I know
we did yeah well it's I know it's I
totally agree with you and it is a real
problem the the the justice system with
respect to to to drug sentences and the
way we police you know it started with
Nixon because he want to go against his
enemies and what does inner cities and
liberal hippie white people have one
thing in common which is drugs and he
went after them and people they used to
work with Nixon said this is a disaster
it was a really bad thing for the
country and I you know George shows who
used to work for Ronald Reagan's
Secretary of Treasury and things like
that even he's saying through coverage
in Stanford saying we need to legalize
drugs and Milton Friedman to the
economist he's dead now but these are
not like some drug fiends
these are super conservative people
supporting Nixon and yeah Reagan they
just think that drug policy is a
disaster absolutely disaster you know I
agree so futile so this is one of the
things I do and I try to use some of my
money medical lab to do a legal magazine
but you know if anyway if people could
help and donate money and things like
that where can they go to kickstart
yoshiji end calm and there's a donate
section or you could go illegal magazine
and email them you want to do any money
but we're trying to print five thousand
issue I mean I like to release ten
thousand issue that I magazine and help
I mean people in San Francisco's been
very open like we have problem in Berlin
they were very mistrustful of the
program but the people who are helping
with the drug issues in San Francisco
they've been very kind they really want
to help people with drugs and hopefully
we get published in January so we're
we've been looking for writers artists
and Tommy if you could write at Davi
fantastic I told my write about when I
oh dude oh yeah to be the first American
issue of the illegal manager yeah we
would love it call speaking of just a
change a topic here but I'm [ __ ] my
pants
no we had this artist this set in a
while back only we played it with cholos
when they try ketchups I love this
Carlos like you know yeah I know I spent
trying kale chips for the first time
like they've never been given you know
what kale chips are no like potato chips
made from kale like this oh no
so it's like oh that's like a fancy
white people food right exactly super
white yeah so this is them trying it
yeah yeah look like some weed and and
and then they gave them kombucha - yeah
Oh something else I think us matters
right up a peg - this is the chips they
all think it looks like we cuz it
totally does it's like it looks like
nugs like a little nut you know cuz it's
all dried and kind of curled up and it
looks like a dried up that if I show my
dad this he'll be like oh don't start
breaking this table up and like let's
let's break it up like oh my god
surround looks like it don't make you
want to be like that's right like I like
enough
I like it our first pot like we're like
what am I really that disintegrated in
my mouth
yeah like a crumble and weird like well
first I didn't like it but then kind of
let me break it up good I want more
kombucha
then they have a thing on them on a
National Geographic the kombucha there
was a try but you know was that Jim no
that's that girl from YouTube yeah I can
watch these guys try [ __ ] all day did
you see the video where they had these
three women between 60 to 80 years old
and they're trying marijuana for the
first time yeah it's pretty cool yeah
they start giggling within 20 minutes
did you we have we got this pulled this
back out for you because what a half and
this happens in the business this is
after a guy and a girl shot a scene do
usually guys come aside you know okay
yeah
dum dum yeah my birth controls plant not
even thinking about it is that pretty
common yeah there I mean depends on the
girl if you're professional do you think
making this as a business
yeah but there's other goofy ones like
you know whatever goes yeah that's right
yeah no this one's in it good did you
feel really bad for them jerk off it's
the same it's the same [ __ ] story
there's always one like go see their
family they're upset
you know I mean yes answer on-site
please it's like hoop dream right
remember at the end of the documentary
the coach like okay one leaves there's
another one we'll replace that person
right right you know but it is kind of
like that it's a revolving door and
these girls don't make like yeah here's
the listen to listen to her her money
talk maybe they gave me an extra dollars
for that and finally he told only like
40 something bug so ethoxy bucks I get
to keep for to cream pies and she gets
to keep $60 because plan B is only 40
right guys come inside he's got a bad
rap I'm always hustling getting that
money yeah if they're doing a couple
porn things that every famous and going
to row stripping because you're like a
hit liner the point of stripper verse in
the headline right that's one thing but
the money situation is really weird now
you know cuz companies that are making
same kind of money and there's so many
free porn tube [ __ ] is that what skilled
money-making tube sites yeah I mean that
the man for porn is never gonna change
it's whether you get collect money for
it right yeah
that's the problem that's what we're
talking about before the show before I
started taping is that why even do porn
now if you're a woman you may as well
just be a prostitute be a hooker and
that way you can have a life like poor
bree olson she's you know living in
indianapolis trying to be normal no she
can't because everybody knows she did
more yeah it's stupid now to even do it
it's just being a hooker you dirtbag
your dirtbag
on me Oren's started doing private you
make money but that's different it's
harder to get famous now is yeah I mean
the stars that I know over older [ __ ]
like belladonna you're jenna jameson
your terror i don't know who's okay I
don't really know I don't know the big
star is know who's a big star of right
now that we don't know about that's like
the megaspore know does it exist I was
gonna have AIDS
yeah I don't know if that that paradigm
exists anymore
which which sucks you know it really
really is tough I mean out I don't think
you're I don't think you don't have
anyone like such a great level Fame or
Tara Patrick who's a she's an empire
like she she was and not anymore it's
it's fallen off for what's-what's ago I
mean when when she was started she was
the first girl to be on cover up an
ounce and Playboy's Empire it's never
been done before you know but every time
I see this figure were like Forbes like
top ten money-making foreign star I
never believed that figures at all it's
not like if I can [ __ ] to me
you think that it's inflated I don't
know why they get this number because I
I talked to Sasha and stuff in like like
she just laughed like I wish that's true
I really wish she was because she had
big money shouldn't make a lot of money
now right she makes money doing other
things right form because you know
foreign you once you make movie that's a
you know the other thing she could be
money mayhem doing well she makes pretty
decent money looks like DJing do you
think that's your business
she flies all over the world so she
escorts no no no she's got she deejays
and she wrote a romance novel and it was
bestseller in Russia in Spain like I
said like I don't know what all that now
DJing was she's a known deejay like
people request
I guess because her I don't know how
good she is DJing but like because over
her name attached to it people pay money
she's big and Russia she's huge
did you know when the Russian Baker
Crimea Crimea Russians government used
her as propaganda saying sasha grey
volunteered to be nurse and she was
killed in action things like that hear
about the early in a year yeah I heard
about obviously the Crimea part but I
didn't know anything I called it like
she's like yeah we were laughing like a
she of Russian descent is she a ruski
she's Greek she's everyone she's had a
vision because her eyes but she's just
not just nothing Asian but she's most
popular in Russia I don't know what it
is
you never know which cultural you know
niche now are you open to me DJing more
well Tom wants to become a DJ and you've
done that before
dude I mean I want to really get into it
like you shared yeah so that's that
every time he does a big show he does DJ
and stuff - they love it he does it
himself now before the show I told you
man I thought he hired he'll show up at
DJ and things like that he's really good
that's what I'm saying a DJ my after
parties with DJs that you we toured with
when you went to England with her it's
been bad DJ spam bang is starting from
scratch
great I don't believe it oh yeah those
guys are so much fun yeah and we were
with like there wasn't but you know what
the scratch head is a Beyonce awesome
those guys are way better than all this
other pop oh yeah yeah part of you have
to do is showmanship I don't know what
they do so different from those guys
were actual skills and I don't
understand if you're into it you should
you should do it I [ __ ] told you well
okay we yeah I think you should
it could be she's really she's really
against it why she just thinks it's too
juvenile and just like I shouldn't I
shouldn't get my equipment and start I
told her it's my passion you know I'm
not good now but that doesn't mean I
won't get better at it and then I could
tack it on in my shows III think yeah
when you become super famous and I know
you guys will and you have DJing that
name of long will preaching that like
income category DJ really I am I didn't
think about it that way oh Sh
I mean that that like why not you know I
mean imagine let's say I get just but
you know a little more famous and then I
go I have my stand-up show at whatever
venues in a nice theater and then
afterwards you can come I'm gonna
scratch at this clutter audition oh you
know rap well you love nightlife I mean
you're always out until
it's garbage yeah but you know [ __ ] Tom
I'll be no serious about this hoorah
this is music kids listen to this crap
you is so good you are so good
don't encourage like ESPN Sports
announcing the prize yes they're so good
one of these football shows you're so
good and you obviously you'll be so much
funnier than a guy doing that you're
right there cuz I look III know just
enough when you're talking like this
[ __ ] knows what he's talking
about
I do love football I can I tell you
these old [ __ ] on these ESPN all
these pantless shows you watch yeah
all these are hundred year old white
guys they look like [ __ ] droopy dog
they look like they're dead they
wouldn't let a woman that ugly on
television meanwhile it's for old [ __ ]
POS you need to be on this stuff you're
so good so good god damn it who do we
call so III think I could see like you
know I'm my one of my favorite thing the
lesson every week is Bill Simmons I love
that guy yeah he he became famous
nationally because he's able to talk
about Boston sports which is only
particularly the fans for Boston only
but he's able to put pop culture
reference to make everyone in the
country appreciate it right you're a
funny guy you could make more than my
reference where's you with the
philosophy and a vine sucker you're very
funny and I could see you talk show
where
helping people with you know yeah with
life yeah I was that kind of a white
Oprah over here I loved we just leave
Yoshi to be our agent that's all what
are you gonna become an agent so you can
make all our dreams come true you you
guys gonna it's gonna happen but but the
philosophy stuff boy I listen to that
you're very good at what do you do I
could see you doing tech conference
seriously comedy a philosophy combining
dirty that means you do get to flex that
muscle with that's the approach I do
yeah I get to talk [ __ ] you've been
doing work by the way I see our
listeners I hope they appreciate you
know the funny thing that they do it
during the TED conference yeah they have
a bail conference you know what that is
no remember Bill and Ted whichever city
they have a TED conference these
goofballs will have a conference with a
goofy [ __ ] like hilarious they have a
cuff like learn to take [ __ ] stay out of
you guys should do that conference for
the TED conference like hey you can't
afford to go to TED Conference come to
your mom's house conference that's
really funny sure like I read how much
does it cost to go to a tank it's a
really expensive five thousand to go
yeah and you I think you have to get I
don't know I don't know how that works
on weight as an audience member you have
to pay a lot it's your life who can
afford it I gotta look these white nerds
but you guys could do a conference every
city with TED Conference agree your mom
house conference I love that's kind of
what we do and your mom sounds live it's
just us talking about shooting with
people but yeah you should have
conference it's a very important issue
have you ever you have to apply to go
I'm asking you very have you ever done
that stuff pooping on people I did that
once injured
me but it's not my [ __ ] on or that you
should had a puss it back over me I'm
not a weirdo yeah yeah clearly What's Up
babe the cost to go to this how much is
it Ted calm okay first of all you apply
see if you qualify you know I'm sorry
today an audience map and to pay I'll
[ __ ] them when you apply you'll need to
provide your credit card information if
we approve the application we will
notify you and charge your card two
business days later everybody boycott
going these these snobs that's why you
need to have your mom's house conference
via same week I gotta tell you this
let's look at their xk joule and follow
it's a greater then it says membership
options and benefits yeah this is tied
into the application process the
standard one is standard conference
membership benefits i guess you get to
go to these you get conference
attendance online networking access and
conference video archive that's sold out
so there's no available for this next
one which is in vancouver february 15 to
19 $8,500 $8,500 level one is still
available you can apply if to apply for
them to accept your money okay you get
the donor button benefits you get the
conference attendance online networking
access conference video archives plus
recognition in the program let's see you
get early access to you know you get in
the theater early stand standby seating
there's a private event early renewals
the ted book club that is $17,000 who's
affording these nerd there's another
level the level is a it's a TED
conference patron membership a special
five year membership category it's
further support Ted's goals with a more
substantial annual contribution you must
apply also for this you get the you know
all the stuff that I mentioned before
plus VIP Hotel assistance concierge
meeting rooms and get this my friend
Eddie Wang got kicked out of the show
because he left a conference and did DVD
sa thing and they got mad at him
not only that speakers do not get paid
and too he was telling me like he had to
share a room with another speaker and
things like that it's a big money making
thankful well this this level is 150
thousand yeah then how about we just
watch it free on YouTube like everybody
just sounds great so Eddie what do you
want
or was he a speaker he was a speaker
you're supposed to even after you give
me the speech you're supposed to stay at
the hotel I went to conference to mingle
with the other speaker what now he left
middle of it the DVD is saying he was
one of the first one ever to get kicked
out a TED conference and also they were
mad at Sarah Silverman for using her
jokes she's hilarious how you invited
her and you know what she's about she
did exactly she's hilarious she made fun
of what did she make fun of you remember
she said that she wanted opt the baby or
something but you know responsibly this
and that so she went adopt the baby what
cancer so this person will die within
six months you know what kind of person
would do that she goes amazing person
itself yeah she was great but yeah they
got mad at her because what a bunch of
nerds they're just like fake outrage and
bunch of [ __ ] baby I've said that
everybody's offended yeah
that's so funny that she did that I love
her so much warning she's great I love
her so maybe you guys should think about
really funny like an anti to Wyatt why
mhm conference conference and we can
invite other like-minded podcasters
right yeah talk about their bowel
movements too it's so important it's so
how are your bowel movements with these
medical oh good one not this study but
last one yeah every day they'll check
your vitals make your okay but they also
ask you about AE which is adverse affect
and nobody wouldn't say anything like
alright I guess I'm the only problem
Erica having problem because my [ __ ] is
green I was [ __ ] me reading for that
whole time yeah in which which test was
for this was Alzheimer's medication and
god my [ __ ] was completely like Shrek
green Wow
and did it was it like a soft or hard
it's hard hard green cheese coming out
of my [ __ ]
that's amaze green [ __ ] yeah green [ __ ]
you had some hot ones last night I think
was the night before yeah wait hot fours
yeah four and a half yeah always see I
think that's your wheelhouse is the hot
fork
I have a tomorrow workout at noon oh
you're gonna [ __ ] yeah I think you guys
explain to me what's the number range
means again one to seven do I know I
took it home but this is a kind of
conference I'm gonna do a 27 one is real
bad I mean that's the part or hard yeah
hell it's you're constipated you're
dehydrated rabbit pellets really really
you know like passing glass in fact when
I was [ __ ] green I remember I had to
[ __ ] bad but I can [ __ ] it it was so bad
wasn't paying I have to put my finger in
my [ __ ] and break this [ __ ] into half
yeah I've actually thought of doing that
so many it was hurting so bad because it
was clogged yeah right my dad told me
about this he did this when and he had
to go to the doctor and it was it was
like a warning sign they were like you
really need to hydrate a lot more they
were they were really concerned for him
man I was drinking a lot it's just the
medication I think boy right and did
your dad put his own finger up his
[ __ ] yeah yeah god damn it yeah do
you know
you know black salami by the way I don't
think we've ever brought this up to you
know what time you want to see something
big
yeah oh yeah okay but what you don't
know what caused the green [ __ ] or you
do it was the mannequin yeah when I
stopped taking it stop being green so
you had someone [ __ ] on you in Germany
so he said are you sure I mean I keep
hearing Jim Norton talking about it like
or I'll try I don't want to be like he's
done it
Jim Jim is famous for that yeah I don't
know that being [ __ ] on or [ __ ] on
why don't and that's one of his kings he
likes that he loves it yeah what's the
what do you think that you've never
heard this before no we love Jim but I
know you and it's his sons not cheap
like he bit two three four hundred bucks
for something oh I figured that was real
cheap
I figured 20 dollars for that yeah
there's a lot of people that would take
a [ __ ] on someone okay damn it okay so
anyway so like shift point I know just
like Germans like the kind of [ __ ] that
like stick on your body where it's a
Japanese like the slippery [ __ ] kind of
bounce off your chest
mm-hmm and you put a tarp on what does
Jim put it to hurt our bond I think so
all right
skins I got one of those brown clear
plastic bag
oh [ __ ] doesn't actually hit him I don't
think I think I think he told me like
clear plastic over his chair well i-i've
had a an idea for an art Expo for years
that I really want to make happen which
is that like we go into like a warehouse
okay and like so it has like 60 foot
ceilings right right and then up on a
level like let's say 30 feet up it's a
glass walkway yeah and there's four
glass toilets yeah with glass tubing
yeah and then we have different people
with different body bills different
races and they go up there and they they
just [ __ ] and everybody below watch is
it
fall down so you have like a big fat
white guy a skinny asian girl like you
know and then so it's just like a [ __ ]
Expo I think that would be really really
that's very clever thank you
now this could be like your TED Expo and
I mean I think it's very it's more for
the artsy crowd it's not yeah I really
don't know I know this is a sorry I
don't know what it is about German
culture but like they're they have
fetishes by the way this is what's
keeping me off of ESPN I think yeah the
Germans are known for shiza porn they
love it right I wonder what that is
Michael Michael Lewis talked about in
his book during the German financial
crisis and he even said in Frankfurt one
of the building look-alike giant toilet
throne but you know it go back in their
religion but yeah it's something to do
with Martin Luther I'm like oh okay he
just sits on you're weird so I don't
know what it is but at least they don't
have a shame about it which I like you
know yeah like that's a like a normal
body function and anytime you make that
weird you're causing more problem you
know so it's better to normalize it
that's art you know what that's been our
mission all along your mom's house it's
always been a higher goal right Tom
absolutely yeah well you know we we we
tried to help that kid Diego yeah we did
help Diego right yeah so that's Diego's
a a guy we found online who wants to get
into fart born and put his phone number
out there and we kind of put it out to
our listenership and why do you think
what's the psychology behind it like I'm
not making any sort of judgment thing
but why do you think there well what is
it about it that you think they like you
don't I don't know I wish somebody could
explain that I know me I honestly I
can't be I don't know because my my
spectrum doesn't go I don't know I can't
even empathize with it like I have a
hard time with vardaman with sexualizing
yeah
you come here I get emotional but please
I'm praying that if any white males out
there listening I'm 31 years of age I'm
not drinking and the bills I made I was
never drinking in out serious and this
is not a joke please I live in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania and right now
this is the middle of October Christmas
will be like in two months please please
it's not it's still like warm here like
is that the do you talk to him before oh
yeah yeah yeah it's not [ __ ]
this is not [ __ ] no no hey you know
if that's what you it's not harming
anyone no no no we're very pro whatever
you're into for sure at this show yeah
but I don't know so different Joe
Rogan's broadcast [ __ ] an [ __ ] in
four words we're trying to help the
world too you know
yeah we're trying to help a world in our
own way but yeah that's that's our
little our little boy Diego are our fart
son wait so do you guys what do you find
out it's a little beautiful guppy so
it's gonna be a little boy it's a boy
yeah thank God
we'll be Chinese people ooh happy the
way of course yeah yeah I do there's
gonna be so many farts and balls and
dicks in my house I'm ready for it I'm
excited I can't wait because I think two
mom's gonna be taking him to football
games of course do you think you'll ever
have a girlfriend Yosh I have a lot of
clothes female friends but does this
make sense
annually in Japan they don't have a
predominant religion you you every the
three major ones that's different things
you know if you're getting married
Shinto rituals if somebody dies Buddhist
rituals in day to day ethical way of
dealing with people being kind to people
yeah
my I like I don't really like I like
having sex with the girls I don't have a
lack of relationship with them
I like having female friends here but
like I don't want to let it mix sex with
them because that's then it always
complicate things I think you think so
you don't think you could have a
friendship and an emotional intimacy
with someone and have sex with them like
you see with that person but right not I
think once you bring sex like that's my
history like we get mad at each other
and not friends anymore you think sex
would ruin the the intimacy of a
friendship a relationship oh yeah I
think so I mean that's that's my bulimia
I'm crazy so I have problems you know
yeah but yeah you know obviously it's a
problem but I just got to work
well it's you're working around it
though it sounds like it's working for
you whatever you're doing so I don't
have friends you know like you know my
friend ho Sanna just went back to New
Zealand he's really fun talking to her
you know and I obviously Len head
Burke's you know why effects live and
III I love you guys are friends yeah and
I I love talking to you I adore you and
like Aiko Tanaka Rosie trend you're like
my kid sisters you know yeah but III do
have female friends by like I don't know
how to do that how to cross like how did
have both sexual and intimate it's just
not it's not happening in your brain I'm
friend with Sasha great and and I like
adore her too but like I never could
even imagine thinking in a sexual way at
all yeah you think of her strictly
platonic
I like having those relationships more
than having sex with a girl you know
yeah yeah
you know I won't say over the years
we've known you now for a while you come
into the show this is probably the
mellowest
and and you seem very balanced you seem
like you're in a good place right now is
that is that accurate
yeah it's primarily because I'm anding
my podcast and there's been the stuff
that
bothered me for a long time but I'm
gonna talk about it the second to last
episode
why are you are you ending it because
you're going abroad now I start feeling
like work you know and I'm getting
burned out and I don't want to just put
stuff on the foot sake of just putting
it out there but I'll be happy just
ending it but yeah I've been thinking
about this for like last year or so and
like I know exactly what I want to talk
about but stuff that I never talked
about I mean kind of mentioned little
bit to you guys in people who are close
to me but that an end is near in a
positive thing you know like I think I
could move on in 46 in like I'm funny
region like a great hockey serious more
comfortable amazing place you know yeah
you dye your hair
no great it's just dude you look how do
you have no great yeah probably does
medical testing stuff I'm joking I'm not
even joking but I'm crazy
hookers keep you young but you you do
not like a heavy into it babe yeah I
don't have to explain myself
you're never judgemental you will say
like you know I mean you were concerned
for me like you said like you know I
don't want to lecture you but if you
want to help I have a good therapist you
know like you're you were never yell at
me or trying to force me to do anything
and that's why everyone from anyone you
know I mean like I know that you cared
and I care about you guys and you're
very kind but with me screaming yelling
like the way my temper at temperature
was relationship with Dave Choe that
that [ __ ] doesn't ever work for me that
[ __ ] will never work for me do you guys
speak at all anymore or no it hasn't
it's been I haven't talked to him since
of April of 2013
oh wow okay I text him once when he got
in trouble for the whole rape then last
year but and did you get a response back
or no yeah he you know it was just like
a casual thing you know he said
something stupid it never happened he's
not a sexual rapist at all he just been
making up some stupid story and all the
outrage grew lips I got mad at her me
yeah you know I could say crazy stop I
never have to worry you know I say um
you know I kind of racial sexual crazy
stuff that [ __ ] I will never worry
people getting mad at me but he has
money and no uh you know famous you know
yeah he should be saying that because
he's I have no money like you want to
see me go hey I don't give a [ __ ] you
know oh gosh I feel like I'm a better
place I'm ending it in January I talk
about everything in fact once I talk
about it I like you to listen to it I
love the kind of philosophy podcast oh
sure
yeah well let me let me know when you're
ready oh you guys could pick any number
a topic you know we should do why don't
we do prostitution dad and you know I'd
like to talk about that the episode I
did prostitution but the third one is
there's like five or six old Japanese
movies I would like you to watch they're
amazing and well write him down I'll
watch him by the way we didn't bring
about this is a news story that came
about about a week ago we didn't do in
our last episode that a man in Texas is
accused of assaulting his girlfriend
after she refused to smell his armpit
CBS 17 reports that yeah Robinson
Pinilla bolivars girlfriend said the
argument started while she was washing
dishes and he asked her to smell his
armpit when she refused an argument for
poorly ensued she was hit in the back of
the head with a closed fist and held up
against a knife he's he was arrested a
traffic - he told authorities he did not
threaten the woman that he threw the
knife into the sink angrily he's being
held on $25,000 bond my whole thing
basically is just fine as long as mattis
okay these meds just smells you know and
in Florida this was I think I think it
was Texas right it yeah
Midland Texas I just feel like been to
Midland you you have to respect your
partner and find out what she likes and
you got to work what around that yeah I
mean I mean would in that situation
your girl she wants you to smell her
armpit but you don't like armpits what
do you do there you just don't first her
like I like licking armpits but some
girls are not into that I remember that
one do you really yeah that's your thing
and do you like it to be now if it has
deodorant doesn't that it doesn't bother
me I mean I wouldn't like if she didn't
take a shower for a long time but if she
just worked out and she's got that like
a work now that's what rush Musk I did
that that doesn't bother me at all
that's kind of the best part yeah yeah
do you like I'm saying if you if there's
deodorant caked under then you're just
kind of getting a chemical taste right I
mean I wouldn't like about another be
upset order but you prefer a nude yeah
now do you like you could literally
taste what's going on in her body I
think really it's like a credit reporter
really a credit report if she's eating
bad like sometime when you're looking a
[ __ ]
and it's tastes sour yeah it's it's a
diet thing you know what I mean oh right
or they smell whatever and and I'm not
attacking women would smell because I
think guys come gross at a o me like
something I write with that diet you
know they can tell right away oh yeah
and like a lot of my gay friends
gentleman like their boyfriend husbands
come tastes weird
you know they know there's some
lifestyle things going sure absolutely
out and how did you stumble on to liking
armpits or did you
it's like pace change over the years
right like they're things like when
you're younger you didn't like certain
food and the change and I think sexually
you're changed too you know so you
didn't know you like armpits though for
a long time I'm a cheap one I don't know
who I asked me to try lips a prostitute
and I tried it in in and I you liked it
yeah he actually likes armpit yeah yeah
smelly are the better or do you like
them deodorized I'm not into like bad
smell but like if it's like I was
feeling town like if it smells like she
just worked out that doesn't bother me
cuz that's fresh sweat okay it's not bad
yeah but like day like days and days do
you like a ripe no no no but he said
that um you can basically taste what's
going on in her body like first
like in the armpit it's just like under
couch yeah you can like you can tell
something's going on with the diet
absolutely how do you know this because
being pregnant like your your body
changes so much sure I feel like I smell
different
just everything coming out of me yeah
smells different and there is you're
beautiful but you're my [ __ ] smells
different my farts my sweat well I mean
obviously you're [ __ ] for two people
yeah over time right now browning for
two yeah yeah it's it's totally it's all
connected and your diet for sure yeah
for sure if you didn't we have a friend
who when the husband ate McDonald's she
could smell it in his sweat oh I bet
yeah in his farts in his fart in the
fart she started and she was she would
go you ask there fart smell sniff oh
sure oh yeah but there's my friend said
he was like caught you know he would be
like he'd fart and she would go get
mcdonalds things like i would hate to do
that but you do it like even if you're
alone you eat it whatever certain foods
bath when you fart you like mine
precious like too much meat and alcohol
it's not a good yeah beer steaks
whenever have a big steak i get those
beef farts where you're like horrible
yeah they are really something man you
know it makes you finalize who's like
salads like kale when we have salad at
home you yeah I don't like those yeah
you soon as you hot sticky you know it
too it's just it's it's pretty immediate
you know yeah doesn't take that long to
talk yeah I mean sometimes it's the
seafoods - yeah it'll be something I
don't expect but like I go get sushi or
something and then I think it's it you
know it's different bacteria it's
different you know working in your
assistant your guts and then immediately
those those farts and those dumps I
don't know what it is I mean I can't say
yeah every agent which at least Japanese
people
we don't really sweat like other nice no
I know and don't sweat and deodorants
not a big business in Japan either dirty
and disgusting and you guys aren't as
fat and I think part of that is because
you don't eat dairy there's no cheese in
your day oh yeah I think that's it I
think part of it is yeah you guys need
like protein and vegetables right it's
their poop oh yeah yeah it is a bull
it's true all right well I think we
should wrap this up oh okay
Yoshi any last anything else you wanted
- it's a fart medley lots only kinda
heavy as I'm working on - comic books
one guy Anthony banshees coming up to
pick me up as we speak but good he's
working on my glasses my medical testing
think he want to make comic book on that
and my friend Mark Jones he is his
sister's married to Jonathan Bronstein
who is the Patrice and Jim Lawrence
manager but I told him somebody I was
talking at one time about it's kind of
like science fiction and philosophy he
liked it so much he want to make comic
book order that's great that's really
cool so that's pretty much it I've been
doing podcasts going on the road I've
been doing more headlining gig so after
you you know just shitty venues you know
but I've been doing a lot of that you
gotta flex that muscle though you know
so it's been good here and I mean I like
to thank Randy puga who let me been let
me stay at his place for last over a
year and he's been very supportive and
we're ready to open a room in k-town hmm
stand-up so if you guys ever want to
come down yeah so yo she did it with the
antique rum that's another person I'm
working the Bob okay so where can people
find you yo she didn't calm right yeah
and at yo she obayashi on Twitter and if
they want to help me with illegal
magazine if you have my idea for
articles
when you want to help people with the
drug issues you know dumb yoshiya gmail
comment or Twitter account Facebook you
know she had Gmail oh yeah all right
that's funny no it's just funny man and
I'll be doing shows in Europe but thanks
guys I love doing the show you guys
never make me nervous you're not
judgmental or fanswers cool I love you
they're just so fun
sweet little Guppies you could ever
imagine
yeah we've always funny to your mom
cells and the way since we moved to the
studio is awesome you're the first guest
we look we still haven't put even all
our things for the wall are still in
boxes and last thing is like I when I
was downstairs looking at the sign with
like you know room 101 CPAs whatever why
mhm no idea what we doing here alright
as always thank you guys for listening
to the show please go to your mom's
house podcast.com Tom Segura dot-com for
my live shows and thousand ranch calm
for Christina's it was a great to have
the great Yoshio by Ashley here and
we'll see you next time bye
jeez you know you gotta pull my god